la grille cause de 3 à 5000 décès au
canada
donc on est loin du compte avec le camp
de viol l'ex minfi
on n'a pas encore eu d'effet à
l'extérieur de la chine il y en a 200
200 2 213 décès en chine
donc c'est beaucoup plus dangereux
pouviez pour que je change que personne
décède la guerre atelier a lâché parce
que j'ai appris que le canada était le
seul pays hors de la chine avoir eu des
décès lors de l'épisode du strass aucun
autre pays avait eu des décès hormis la
chine donc le canada c'est une c'est un
lieu sensible par ya pas eu 40 44
détectée est infecté et environ 44 me de
mémoire est exact on appris par contre
depuis les petites phrases de métro on
sait que nous verrons si on est capable
d'éradiquer la transition
si on emploie des mesures de santé
publique sont très strict alors cv reçus
retransmettent ne sont des contacts
étroits en virée du qui par contact et
toi c'est surtout les contacts familiaux
ou des contacts produit quand une
personne est hospitalisée et les mesures
de santé publique ne sont pas bien
activée on ne porte pas de mac la blouse
la ville la visière 17 euros 6,93 on
isole ratoma les corps ont tracé contact
on isole ses contacts
on va venir à bout rouge certains de
cette épidémie nos commandes est venu à
vous las depuis 2003 2004
depuis tu vas chez l'humain peut-être
que le réservoir animal est encore
présent et pour une réintroduction un
jour pour l'instant on a réussi à
contenir cette épidémie n'a donc je
pense que le lot de problèmes avec le
niveau canadien
mais si ça arrive dans un pays dont les
infrastructures sanitaires sont moins
bonnes
par exemple en afrique un pays d où tu
as écrit pas mal de dommages mais je
pense pas qu'un pays comme le canada les
etats-unis où il ya plupart des pays
européens vont avoir de gros problèmes
avec alice oui au fait docteur boivin il
ya des canadiens qui sont en ce moment
coincé en chine qui vont bientôt être
rapatriés ici c'est sûr que dans les
aéroports on a des protocoles qui sont
en place même dans les hôpitaux aussi le
directeur de la santé publique du québec
l'a dit ces derniers jours
si vous aviez des conseils à prodiguer à
l'endroit de la population ici que leur
diriez vous pour s'en prémunir
mais pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
danger immédiat pour la population de la
ville de roanne
donc les risques sont minimes
pour l'instant je ne pense pas qu'il y
ait eu de telles armes et comme le
docteur la santé publique du québec a
mentionné hier et tout ce qu'on connaît
à tape dessus je ne fais pas ainsi que
les pouilles virus est particulièrement
dangereux bien entendu cas c'est quelque
chose qu'on connaît mal j'en connais pas
tellement
oui mais parlons des mesures de sécurité
dans les aéroports il ya des différences
entre pays présentement notamment entre
les etats-unis et le canada
on a tenté des expériences lors de
l'épidémie du strass au canada pour
contrôler les passagers qui arrivaient
qui était plus sévère
on a dépensé ou de l'autre 7 millions $
et on a répertorié aucun aucun passager
malade mais dans ce cas ci est ce que
les soyons raison de s'inquiéter du
retour au pays par exemple de canadiens
qui se trouvera un cheese faire un pays
ont pris des mesures fermes quand un
rapatriement de la population on compare
la france
l'australie les états-unis canada
ce que j'ai entendu pour la part des
autorités canadiennes c'est qu'il n'y
aurait pas de quarantaine au retour des
ressortissants canadiens de de chine
s'est joué avoue qu'il est plus
surprenant on s attendait à voir une
quarantaine au moins de sept à dix jours
parce que les premières données qu'on a
les autorités chinoises parlent d'une
période d'expiration de cinq jours mais
avec un étendue que parler de 2,2 trois
jours jusqu'à 7 à 10 jours la période
d'expiration ces deux hommes la période
entre le moment qu'on est infecté il
marque développent des symptômes donc
qui veut dire quelqu'un qui arriverait
aujourd'hui au canada
portage dieuze et répondre seulement des
symptômes très pâle et ça m'a isolé et
pourrait développer les symptômes
quelques jours plus tard donc moi je me
serais personnellement attendu à ce que
des mesures de quarantaine
appliquée pour les ressources 5 qui
revient de chine et dans ce cas là
qu'est ce que la population canadienne
du pressoir pour se mettre à l'abri de
ce virus là moi ce que je comprends
c'est que même si un peu de mesure de
quarantaine en voir un suivi étroit
alors je pense que de toute façon il n'y
a pas de raison de s'inquiéter
y'a pas de foyer actif de multiplication
du virus au canada en ce moment pas
encore une chose soit à surveiller par
exemple c'est des foyers de une
réplication du virus à l'extérieur de la
chine a fait il ya quatre ou cinq pays
qui rapporte les échos qui ont été
contractées en dehors de la chesnaie et
c'est important de vérifier que satin
pour plusieurs générations de cours
effectivement ça peut débouler dans la
population en général contenu à
l'extérieur de la chine en même temps
c'est assez étonnant parce que bon en
chine parce que pendant fin peu la
géopolitique l'homme et ils ont rien
appris du strass c'est quand même un
pays qui surveille sa population à un
niveau assez inédit comment une épidémie
puisse éclore aussi rapidement et avec
des chiffres aussi énorme dans un pays
ultra surveillé et en plus qui a déjà
connu des épisodes de connaux
coronavirus est important il a évolué et
on compare 1,2000 trop avec les îles
2009 2020 avec celui-ci
c'est aller beaucoup plus vite la
divulgation des dicos le partage des
fréquences du virus on parle de premiers
cas sont apparus en chine de pneumonie
due à un agent indéterminée à ce moment
là à la mi décembre
on ne fait le lien assez rapidement dans
quelques jours quelques semaines que si
le psychologue commun d'un contact avec
un marché de poissons et d'animaux ce
marché a été fermé dès le 1er janvier et
le 8 janvier à l'identifier l'agent
causal de ses primes au niveau peut être
encore nos vieux le 12 janvier des
séquences du nouveau camp de virus
étaient partagés avec m donc on réagit
frapna
maintenant le problème encore une fois
si les fameux marché de volailles plus
d'animaux sont ouverts au grand public à
l'air libre qui amènent des contacts
potentiels et des vivres sont chez les
ch et l'animal ou chez loiseau et il est
humain qui fréquentent une archi le
docteur boivin va falloir se quitter là
dessus ce fut extrêmement nourrissant de
vous écouter la à la fois un peu plus
inquiète un peu plus rassurés on voit
son ca au moins croient surveillés
france est important
à surveiller merci beaucoup docteur
merci prochain à dr guy boivin
microbiologiste et infectiologue au
centre urs pilz universitaire de québec
ouais c'est quelqu'un qui connaît le
monde partout au canada qui elle est
reçue des des prix honorifiques
c'est vraiment quelqu'un est très
éclairant way écoutez on est prêt pour
le troisième tour de notre croûte bull
et la réponse a été donnée en entrevue
mais de façon partielle seulement par
docteur boivin d'accord alors voici
troisième on affiche la question 50
boules à perdre je voulais savoir
combien vous en avez leurs vues sur cinq
ans je sais plus moi je sens que j'en ai
30 noms car on a passé on n'a pas dû la
question ça sera pas l'homme d'origine
chance le strass avait fait 5900
victimes en chine premier pays où il y
avait une preuve plus de problème le
deuxième pays c'était rock avec 1650
quatre victimes sont pas des gens qui
sont morts des gens qui ont été infectés
le canada était troisième sur la liste
des pays les plus touchés par le strass
incroyable mais vrai combien de
personnes avaient été infectées au
canada
est-ce que c'est à 1025 est ce que c b
521 au terme d'une année de
contamination est-ce que c'est ces 251
ou est ce que c'est des 125 il y avait
eu 44 morts je le précise donc ça vous
donne peut-être un ordre de grandeur ici
quelle est la bonne réponse comme une
personne dont canadiens avaient été
infectés sur toute la région toronto
alors ouais ça se comprend on a beaucoup
d'asiatiques qui me veut sur la côte
ouest canadienne
puis à ton monte aussi attentes aussi a
b c ou d
on a besoin de réponses 1027 b&b 521
faites vos jeux rien ne va plus la bonne
réponse
on affiche les 5 étoiles avec un de ses
gardiens personnes décédées cette série
c'est sérieux ce jour aura goûté au
plaisir de vous avoir ici un studio pour
répondre à nos questions et pour poser
des questions à nos stages et aux effets
et puis aujourd'hui ne fait pas
exception même si on parle d'un jeu qui
est à ces gars là j'ai je voulais vous
faire sourire je pense j'espère en tout
cas c'est notre image la semaine vous
devez deviner et je réponds seulement
par oui ou par non quelle est cette
image
j'attends vos questions quelle est
l'image de la semaine selon vous l'image
de la semaine n'ont pas trouvé l'image
de la semaine
les corps qui ont été repêchés dans non
ça c'est la cedh a retrouvé le
cette semaine en tout cas les toulonnais
poteau genève tous les mentonnais je
n'ai pas de tous les mentonnais non
serment mieux encore ils sont
généralement cachés sous l'eau c'est pas
la bonne réponse
est-ce que c'est aux états unis ça se
produisait aux etats unis puisque c'est
le président non ils n'ont pas ce que
nous on en a c'est le nom mais moi non
non non non non c'est pas les élections
américaines
non non à la campagne pas du tout pas du
tout ça n'a rien à voir avec les
élections ça à voir avec quand même
c'est pas la météo c'est pas la science
est un de ces grands sujets c'est parce
qu'il est médiatisé souvent ah non je
pensais aux couples non je ne sais pas
un procès non non c'est arrivé dimanche
ouais dimanche aux environs de 3h c3 et
moi je suis pôle sport également entendu
le nom risque est que tous n'ont pas
cette personnalité très très très très
grand soin de masquer est bon alors l'un
des plus aisément avec sa fille de 13
ans voilà un journaliste qui dit qu'il
était mort avec les quatre enfants qui
l'avaient non non non non c'est pas un
c'est fait avec sa fille une amie de sa
fille des parents de cet ami l'a et
combien ils étaient 39 9 mai lors de ce
qui est elle ou avait annoncé le décès
le tabloïd avant que la famille soit en
cours avant que la police informée moi
je les presque suivi en direct dont
j'accompagnais mon fils un saison à ces
pratiques de basketball et donc
l'entraîneur vers 3h30 nous dit bah
écoutez écoutez jacques aubé mauvaise
nouvelle on lui demande qu'est ce qui se
passe il dit kobe bryant tous les
enfants étaient combien nombre
oui très très connue des jeunes est un
sportif très engagé auprès des engagés
auprès des jeunes très très prolifique
durant sa carrière parce qu'il a marqué
plus de 33000 points à 8 sont 3000
panier et il était le troisième meilleur
comment dire ça c'est buteur ou quoi au
basket ball on parle de quoi marqueurs
de l'histoire du basket dans son nikon
et il se trouve que la veille de son
décès lebron james à l'abattre certains
aimeraient avoir la se positionne à la
dure à la deuxième position au 2e rang
juste après à tailler un autre avant lui
joue mieux le nom
est-ce que ça maintenant c'est pas mal
comme ça on va ouvrir non pas moi votre
fiston il ay d'aussi grave et gras où il
est il est assis pas mal trompe ou son
âge mais bon il aime le basket
ouais mais donc ça dure touché
énormément énormément
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
merci beaucoup d'un merci des cellules
terroristes avec nous également cette
semaine
merci la semaine prochaine ses fans à la
semaine prochaine dans votre cas est
allé sur votre congé samedi ce qui va
montrer à ma place excellent
[Musique]